keep it here
what's this one this is the uh what's
your point
battery let's run out of batteries let
me see this thing
maybe you're not doing it are we
officially live or not we're officially
live okay
episode number 62. adam how are we doing
tom
good morning friends get the energy up
in here let's get that
off the energy up in here let's get it
started
[Applause]
stick to the case studies bro no comedy
no singing
stay in your lane last night we had the
last two days were board meeting days so
we had a bunch of people in town we're
having the meetings going back and forth
yes sir
last time we get back to the house it's
late ten o'clock we're sitting there i'm
like let me watch this
uh few minutes of this lakers uh golden
celtics game i'm thinking i'll watch a
couple quarters and i'm gonna no you
just said celtics game goals
right uh steph lakers against uh well
east coast west coast you could go to
sleep about 9 45.
here it's midnight welcome baby east
coast
and then you know steph curry that thing
goes down over time
two turnovers and then lebron james
scores uh the shot and it's game over by
the way
do you know how many points uh draymond
green scored yesterday zero
two points two points zero four five
yeah four four five and forty one
minutes he's gonna
assume he had a bunch of assists and a
bunch of readers you gotta at least give
12 points in a game
like this how big is this contract
remember didn't he sign a giant probably
80 100 the moment he did his field goal
percentage free throw percentage
three-point percentage everything
dropped
meaning he just said i'm a great
defender and that's all it is anyway
he's got to bring more to the table
i think so man i think if you're going
to two points two points two points
two come on homie yeah two so step one
sign a big mega your contract step two
gain 15 pounds step three stop working
the cardio even though you gain the
pounds step four forget about shooting
step five cash those checks here's crazy
thing he played lights out defense
lights out defense i mean the guy was
ridiculous last night in the way he
played defense and
uh but man if he would have scored five
points it would have been over time if
we would have scored six points
yeah two points they would have won they
would have won the game so that's that
that has to be a conversation that
they're discussing with the coaches
draymond you got to shoot that right but
i just
don't know how you see the walk off the
conversations yeah
he's he's a
tom for the first time in his life
watched the
ricky j gervais message at the golden
globes
yeah it was his first time he watched he
hadn't seen it yet what'd you think of
that
i thought it was shocking that one guy
is up there speaking truth
and poking so it was mixing it up he got
away with it
it was it was a lasagna of truth poke
truth poke
truth poke and everybody was really
nervous laughing about it because some
of the people
lasagna veggie lasagna where'd he go no
no this was all
meat he was heading for heart he was he
said uh this is the speech where he said
get up there thank you agent thank you
god let's go keep it moving
he picked on apple and that's where he
looks at leonardo dicaprio and he said
hey
you know we got a problem here if this
thing goes four hours by the end of it
um you know uh leonardo dicaprio's date
will be too old for him
oh and so that that's an easy joke with
leo yeah but that's one of those
you know poke in the heart that you're
not supposed to do in hollywood and then
the rest of it
yeah i i he was really good he looks at
tim cook he says apple do not lecture us
on human rights you with your sweatshops
don't walk up here and say thank you
people thank you my god and everything
just shut up and take your reward and
sit down and that one i thought was wow
that was like
right for the i just thought of
something what he's on the troll list
but like a professional troll oh you
know
he's like a likeable by the way somebody
said yesterday he says you guys forgot
to talk about 50 cents as a troll he's a
troll as well
likable 50 there's likeable
after the conversation we had we talked
about jake paul and takashi yeah there's
feud between the two trolls
controls each other isn't it 20 percent
control
of our rap lyrics trolling in some way
top question for you why did you
like takashi's music so much yeah what
is it like
every time i'm in a car with you you're
listening to it what is this music
is it family friendly is it stuff you
listen to you leaving the church
why do you like takashi's music so much
what i love about it
is the melodic themes wrapped around the
texas blues and it just works
yeah that's it that's it that's it that
makes a lot of sense okay so
a lot's happened the last 48 hours yes a
lot has happened last 48 hours too much
been happening uh i got a haircut
you know adam got a haircut right yeah
well we paid some different prices from
what i understand
here we go all right there we go i need
it i go to get a haircut from this guy i
love this guy
great guy make i had rapper tony make a
video to send to him for me to go to get
a haircut
and then time comes to pay 72 dollars
and 10 cents i'm like 72 bucks for a
haircut not tip
what was it 72 it's uh 70 bucks plus
three dollars for the fee
so three times seven is two dollars and
ten cents so seventy dollars
i carry the two and then i'm not cooking
fine i can respect the two dollars
seventy two dollars for a haircut
and ten cents for the haircut all right
by the way here's here's the first thing
i thought about when i left
and we talked about it after it says why
do you have that reaction to it i said
look i've never paid 72 dollars and 10
cents for a haircut and i've had a lot
of great haircuts
tell me how you determine your pricing
he says well you had an appointment with
me and by the way this guy's a die-hard
valuetainer great guy
sweetheart of a guy you know we had the
other day we went and met him nice guy
and he did a great job michael sent me a
video i sent it to him
i said 7210 not including tip he says
yes because it's appointment only
i said so how so let me look at the
haircut everybody else was thirty
dollars thirty five dollars kids twenty
oh
so there's pricing on the wall pricing's
on the wall but not the 72
and 10 cent pricing that's here so i go
all the way down and on the bottom it
says if you have an appointment it's
five dollars on top of whatever it is
35 bucks appointments no problem he said
celebrity
hair stylist nowadays is 72 dollars and
10 cents by the way you know what is
crazy
he is a celebrity in the barber
community no joke he's got massive
followers when he says celebrity
haircuts that means because you're a
celebrity no no no for
him the the the hairstylist and barbers
nowadays
who have a following they get these
thousand dollar scissors they get this
equipment you know what's the first
thing i thought about
here's the first thing i thought about
every time i go to get a haircut i
always ask myself
why do barbers do it because think about
the math
35 bucks let's just say you work out a
place 35 bucks the owner takes what part
of the 30
35 50 knows you got to pay a fee for a
chair of course that's the part see the
owner takes uh
uh 20 bucks okay say you take 15 bucks
you keep 15 bucks of it because you got
to pay the rent
so you get another 10 tip that's 25 an
hour 25 bucks it takes an hour to give a
haircut
assuming you give eight in a day that's
how much money in the day two hundred
dollars two hundred dollars
twenty days in a month is what four
grand a month four grand times uh
12 is what 40 grand a year so the fact
that he got paid
60 no 48 thousand dollars a year a good
barber
makes barber makes right it's not a big
month it's not big money
i would think it's more than that to do
the math for me i don't know i just
you just did the math i don't need to
duplicate it so i thought it'd be more
so that's the point
yeah a barber at 35 bucks is only making
50 grand a year so when he charged me 72
i went in the car and the first thing i
said is i'm actually
happy prices are going up for barbers no
hell no
let me tell you why let me tell you why
the fact that there is tears
that people are willing to pay this kind
of money for somebody that does high
quality hair
you do the math on the math on the 7210
how much does he keep on 72 10.
take the tip 15 additional bucks because
you do 20 so it's thank you
whoa so it's 86 bucks well shout out to
caroline
shout out to cold what is going on so
say it's 86 bucks out of the 86 he keeps
60.
so he does eight haircuts in a day
that's what 480
times 20 in a month is what 10 grand a
month now the hair stylist is making
what six figures
good for him so but even at 72 dollar
haircut a great barber only makes
six figures per year okay think about
that they work when they want to work
they're not doing something i don't know
hard labor
here's what i want to find out yeah i
don't know about it there's a lot of
jobs in america how much do you pay for
a haircut
i pay about 35 bucks 35 bucks now you're
in texas not complicated i go
i go uh the most i've ever paid 33 bucks
yeah okay
well you're in texas yeah in la i assume
when you were living you know
living your life in l.a same girl cut my
hair for 10 times i would love to hear
from our audience
ladies and gentlemen how much for the
guys obviously because women actually
want to know what is the most you've
ever paid for a haircut and give us the
city and the state
but i want to know just on average what
they pay what do you pay adam what do
you do who do you got
well he cuts himself yeah save that
money it's usually it's
mario do this year watch this how-to
video on youtube and then every time i
see them in the kitchen together yeah me
and mario well they
usually it's about 35 bucks for a
haircut it's about 70 for celebrities
d-list celebrities are about 25 bucks so
i pay about 25 bucks
you're not a dealer celebrity yeah is
this the person you're going back to
like you've got a regular
you're in a i swear to god folks if you
were here on a daily basis adam's
probably the biggest celebrity in our
office
yes or no is he not the biggest
celebrity in the office employees are
taking pictures just like a regular now
you have a regular
let's see here's the thing that's a big
deal let's see here have you heard i've
noticed over time they're slowly getting
better i don't know if you've heard but
i'm kind of a big deal
you know okay armando lapeda says 40
bucks including beard can you tell us
where where what city what city and
state wilberto rodriguez at 60 bucks i
want to know where
did you say including beer beer beer oh
72 is too much that's 40
for a haircut including a beer including
tip
uh honcho cheese got 45 bucks la
uh 50 bucks brian solaris is the highest
one so far
this one guy says 15 dogecoin
[Laughter]
15 dogecoin that's what that's uh last
week 750.
mobile okay here we go adrian brent
branigan
hundred dollar mobile barber and dc
that's that's good to know the market
price for mobile because you're driving
say you're taking that time
so it's an armored car if it's miami
adrian said 100 bucks 70 bucks
oakland 75 in nashville 47
85 bucks in connecticut that makes sense
what about my boy roland i like his body
he goes my mom gives me a wait
wait a minute 85 and connections cortez
85 in connecticut we have a friend in
greenwich that we need to give his name
to
50 miami and it's mobile he'll come to
you
greg i'm begging you go to this guy
that's a hundred bucks 85 bucks in
connecticut adrian bennett 100 bucks
you know what listen there's some people
that are 50 95 bucks in melbourne
australia
and if you want him to fly out to use
three thousand dollars for that haircut
from australia
what else we got so listen but qantas
has got summer deals
yeah 25 bucks 35 bucks you know uh
50 dollars at home appointment in santa
barbara daniel castillo
family cuts it so you're looking at 50
bucks 60 bucks you know you don't see a
lot of 70.
but i did the math yesterday and here's
what happened when we left he says pat
yeah i'm sitting there he says pat give
us give us some ideas here give us some
wisdom we got a big vision here's what i
told them while we're with them
yesterday okay
and by the way today we're going to
finish the podcast at 10 30. so if
you're with us
hit the thumbs up button so we're going
to go showing it subscribe we got to get
uh time on a flight then we'll be out
here we got appointments to run as well
here's what he asked me at this pat give
me some feedback what do you think i
should do
i said okay i said do you want to be
known
as a great barber or do you want to be a
no known
as a great businessman what do you want
to be known as that's a great question
yeah he says
skill at your profession or run a
business yeah because he says i want to
i want to be known as a great
businessman i said then you got to
change your lens he says what do you
mean i said so let me do something for
you
so i step out i said i want you to think
i'm a celebrity barber
okay and i'm in boca i'm a celebrity
barber in miami
i'm a high premium like you i'm in boca
i'm checking out my competition i decide
to come and get a haircut from you
i walk into your barbershop everybody
knows so they're sitting there they're
listening i said yes
so i opened the door i walk in i said if
i'm a celebrity barber and i sit here at
from which lens am i looking the entire
store here
he says what do you mean i said if i'm a
celebrity barber i'm probably checking
out your scissors
i said i'm probably looking at your 250
scissors pad that's a thousand dollars
that's a great i said if i'm a celebrity
barber i'm watching how you do to fade
i'm watching how you talk to your client
i'm watching your style i'm watching
what products you use i'm watching the
kind of stuff that you have there
do you do massage at the end do you have
a washing at the end do you have beers
what i'm but i'm watching the way you
cut your hair from a celebrity barber
because i'm watching your abilities
right he says yes i said let me go
outside and come back in
so i go outside i come back in i said i
want you to know the next person that's
walking in
is a businessman okay that everything he
looks as through the lens of a
businessman fairy says fair so i walk
out i come back and i sit he says while
i'm sitting here here's all i'm thinking
about
why are those three chairs open he's
losing money right there that guy just
did a haircut i've been waiting here for
30 minutes took him to get a haircut
what's the price 30
he gives him 20 bucks he keeps sending
the 15 bucks here
it took him this long to do a haircut
math i'm doing how many haircuts in an
hour
traffic cost electricity how much money
did he spend how much do those shares
cost
each chair how much is he spending how
much does he make i'm doing the math
right he said yes
i said you don't have the lens of a
business man your lens right now is a
lens of a barber
if you want to scale your business you
got to change the lens and start looking
at your business to scale
not looking at your business as i'm
selling 72 haircuts because a 72
haircut you're making 100 grand a year
so if you got three four four other
barbers you're making two you know a
grand a month off of these guys
you're really making what 161 seven
years that's not a million dollar
business that's a 116 that business so
the biggest challenge for some folks out
there who are either
the celebrity professional realtor or
the celebrity professional
loan officer the celebrity professional
whatever in any community chiropractor
do you want to be that or do you want to
be the one that has 40 chiropractor
offices
20 real estate offices 30 mortgage
office it's a
in order to do the other part you got to
change your lens
simple as that great guy i gave him a
book he says
what do i need to do to get you back
here said i need you to read this book
you read it the moment you finish it
tell me you finish the book write a
paper on it i'll come back to get a
second haircut he boarded a book last
night so i got to go back and get a
haircut i think it's amazing
that number one you walk into the you're
just there to get a haircut
so what i'm seeing here is you're
identifying all the leaks and missed
opportunities in his business
so we we saw you just do this for those
of 100
lucky few that were there at the sls
meeting and now
we just launched the fact that we're
doing the the vault
uh that's going to be what september 1st
these are the types of situations where
you go into a
barber shop and rather than oh okay get
my hair cut boom now you're identifying
leaks boom here you go you got chairs
open
here's the book i need you to read you
just totally changed this guy's life but
you know what's crazy here's what's
crazy here's what's crazy
if you look at tom okay if you look at
uh greg
if you look at you if you look at me sam
everybody in this room here right
the 21 year old pat when he walked into
the mall what lens did he have on what
do you think he was looking for just
looking to buy something i want to look
cool i'm just hanging out the 21 year
old pen when you walked into the mall
you weren't buying anything the 21 year
old pad walking into the mall is only
looking for tight jeans
nice legs nice you're looking for chicks
that's
my only lens was that so it was the lens
right see i gave you a little more
credit than that but
you think too highly of me at the 21
year old the 219 didn't have a lot of
priorities so there you go so then you
look at another person that goes in so
everything about everything
we do okay a mother walks in to a place
okay and they look at the living room a
father walks into the living room says
oh my god look at the view look how sick
this is
look at the hotel look how sick the
windows a mother walks in and says oh
look at the edges of that table if the
kid hits his head we gotta that's the
part
if we can change the lens and the lens
changes by the way half the battle with
what we got in america today
is we got some screwed up people with
lenses because we changed the lens we'd
actually get along and have
good discourse and good discussions and
debates together we have the wrong
lenses on
tom you know what's really interesting
about this and yeah
pat you and i were in la and there was a
really amazing haircutter he was a
celebrity guy i think his name was jose
a bear
you make someone be able to look look it
up no nothing i'm just waiting on my tea
over here oh okay go ahead right under
your teeth
i thought he's a celebrity i don't know
he doesn't get what he wants i don't get
my tea i don't know
we're gonna cancel the whole show we
just we just had the secret cheetos
yeah jose iberi bear i think it was his
name yeah but he was uh he used to wear
like a white cowboy hat
and he had this huge brand and what he
did was he realized that
having all these celebrity clients
wasn't the path to making money
and my understanding was he used himself
as the branded magnet
and he hired really good stylist and so
he turned it into a business where he
always had his chairs full
and he brought great people in that want
to be associated with him and he was
doing
high-end celebrity and then a lot of
wealthy people
and beverly hills i always had a lot of
respect for that i said wow he's kind of
figured this out
that he can only do so many haircuts but
he's the magnet
you know what i'm saying he's the magnet
and so you look like you use your
personality to draw on the traffic
that's a business model some guys are no
that's exactly right and this guy i
don't know
somebody can look it up but he was very
successful in l.a and he was very well
known people would go from the valley
from chatsworth to did he spell his last
name
it was i can say it and i'm probably
butchering it but it was jose
a bear like h-e-b-e-r-t or something
like that but he had a cowboy hat he had
long hair
sounds good he was very slick so if
you're in l.a go check out jose barrett
he may be retired by now but um you know
was that like 40 years ago 30 years ago
no it's back when i was in high school
72 years ago
years ago okay so bitcoin had a rough
week is that fair to say i think we get
right into bitcoin to see what happened
with bitcoin
last seven days have not been the best
seven days for bitcoin a lot of things
been going on with them
the cryptocurrency market suffered a
sharp sell-off on wednesday its value
has now tumbled
by 47 the last 10 days the market cap
for global digital currencies came in at
1.35 trillion
on wednesday down from a peak of 2.56
trillion on may 12th the most recent
plunge was triggered by the people of
bank of china announcement that digital
tokens can't be used as a formal payment
by financial institutions
bitcoin at one point fell as much as 31
to 30 thousand dollars while ethereum
slipped by 44
to 1900 bitcoin still hasn't recovered
from elon musk
climate concerns over its mining process
which sends shockwaves across the
digital
asset ecosystem however having said that
having said that today
today i think bitcoin bitcoin is back up
what bitcoin is back
21 ethereum's back up so they're making
some kind of a progress
ethereum almost at an all-time high
wasn't there all-time high it was at an
all-time high
2800 and they're like right 26.50 or
something this morning no i don't know
where they're at right now but
all i know is it dropped to a uh
all-time
the last seven days it dropped to 1918
and i think at the peak it was 3 300 i
think 3 300 was the number
the audience the comments are coming up
what are your thoughts about what's
going on
i think distribution is at play here any
if you have distribution
you've got places to sell and what china
just said
sorry we're closing the market so no
consumers
um so therefore they lose distribution
and
you know when you have outlets you have
everything when remember in the
beginning when dish network and tesla
and people said we're going to take
bitcoin
now you've got distribution you've got
you know this is why diners club what's
diners club it's a dead credit card
right
american express you know the sticker on
the window american express accepted
here mastercard visa that was the war
and credit cards going through the 80s
and distribution was everything and
what's happening right now
crypto's going down because if there's
not outlets that'll accept it
the value the relative value is going to
go down in terms of
you know yeah spendability and so i
think china
and um oh also um tesla said hang on a
second
we're not gonna take uh bitcoin for a
while maybe it's power reasons
but i think there's a lot of
distribution if it's available
and trading and it's it's in your paypal
it's in your coinbase and you can use it
anywhere
it's got more value and i think what
they have this week is a
social thing on the mining and the
electricity but also
on distribution china saying made in
china don't use a bitcoin
adam what do you think well i agree with
tom there's uh two major stories
that moved the markets this week number
one was china for sure everything you
just said
about basically they're not being able
to uh
make payments and then number two
obviously we've touched on this with
elon musk everything that he did
since his snl appearance everything that
he did to basically dismantle
the belief in dogecoin everything so but
i think this is good
i think this is good to have a shake-up
in the market like this because there's
basically two types of people
there's the hodlers that have been
holding bitcoin since
2012 2015 2017 whenever they got in
they've been
holding and then there's the speculators
who have been just kind of
you know along for the ride and if you
got in
basically this year because think about
it and you've touched on this the last
time we spoke
how many people got a stimulus check and
pumped it right into the markets or
bitcoin or a lot of young people
right so when all you know is up and
nothing ha
you know you bought in at 15 or 20 and
you got to 60
and you put in 10 grand and now you got
50 grand whatever the number is
um you think this is a magical bitcoin
ride like a aladdin
magic carpet ride but the reality is
markets go up markets go down
assets go up assets go down so it's
basically a lesson of how much you can
stomach
so i did an episode on the episode on
bitcoin when it reached the trillion
dollar
market cap um
about basically what the big boys are
doing you know ftm
follow the money what are the big boys
doing tesla at the time and other
companies in that realm were putting
three to eight percent of their cash
reserves into crypto okay cool so use
that
as an example as set for yourself it's a
marker as a marketer
all right so the big boys are getting
them in five bucks to put 30 to 80 grand
oh
whatever but that i did i did interview
a bunch of people at a crypto conference
i'm 99
crypto i'm all in on krypto yeah i don't
use cash anymore yeah
okay well i hope you can stomach a 40
drop a 30
drop a 20 drop in a week so it's a base
basically you're 22. what's what's what
is a 22 year old worried about if you're
25 yeah
if you're 45 with kids with a family and
you're 99
crypto it's a gamble right and it's a
pretty big gamble well you know this
everything when it comes to investments
comes down to asset allocation
by the way somebody just said ethereum
was a 40 i want to be very accurate here
folks
we said 3 300. tom threw me off the
highest ethereum's bin is let me look it
says 4300.
so continue you were saying no basically
you know you you worked uh
uh what was your first job when 911 you
were with um morgan
morgan stanley okay gotcha so you
started off in the investment 4165
all-time high they teach you about asset
allocation and a diversified portfolio
and the 80 20 you know balanced
portfolio 80
stocks 20 bonds whatever it is and then
there's the
the three fund portfolio where you've
got you know your s p
and then you get your international and
then you've got your bonds what have you
in my opinion crypto does need to be a
part of your portfolio at this point
and it's just about how much you can
stomach so for me
five percent is my number right cool
i'll put in this i'll put in that but
for the most part i'm all in on
the s p and and what have you so you
just got to ask yourself
how much you're willing to stomach with
this crypto ride because it was at 60
grand now it's at 30 grand this is all
within a month or two
um but i think one thing for sure that
you you said this the other day
is blockchain here to stay yeah it's not
going away is bitcoin here to stay
yes is are nfts here to stay
yes it's just establishing you know the
market value of these things yeah the
price point
the the real argument that is made
sometimes
is it an investment if it's a currency
is it something that you put in and you
say hey this is a form of an investment
or a currency it's a different topic
there right
if a currency is being treated like a
stock it's kind of weird if a currency
is being treated like a stock
that hey i'm going to invest into you
don't say i'm going to invest into i
understand there is a
a foreign currency folks i get 4x people
are big you got to do
but forex guys don't make you know 350
in the last 12 months you don't hear a
number like that right if you do it's
typically you're you're a little bit of
lucky and some stuff you got going on
that's the only challenge you see with
this
by the way uh the other day uh edward
stone i don't know if you saw what he
said
he said the the best the best thing they
could do for bitcoin is to keep it
private not keep it public
that's that's what it was built for it
wasn't built to be public it was built
to be private
and to him he says i'm a holder i have
crypto
i'm in with this i'm part of the group
but i don't like the fact that it's
public i want it to be private
why is he saying that actually go to why
he's saying that maybe long term he's
worried about regulation
maybe long term he's sitting there
saying man yeah yeah you're sitting
there saying dude this was created not
for me to be a billionaire this was
created for me to be private
for me to keep my life private not
everything is public everybody can find
it i don't want it to be public i want
it to be private
so there's there's can and when edward
snowden says something like that i mean
the guy's got access to attention
people kind of pay attention to it so my
biggest concern has been the same it's
not changed you're just seeing how
volatile it is and
quite frankly for those guys that are
you know going along on it if you
dollar cost average at 30 000 goes back
to 64. you just doubled
if you believe in dollar cost averaging
if you don't you're part of another
community that's anti-bitcoin you're
sitting there saying i told you so i
told you so
everyone everyone has at this point for
the last quarter
everyone can say i told you so if you're
on the
i love it to be more that i told you so
it's for the people that are in the
crypto community i totally agree yeah
and i'm totally and i'm not part of that
community
i'm not part of that community i'm right
in the middle i have very little in it
right but i'm right in the middle yeah
but i respect their opinion and how they
uh uh
you know are true believers in what
they're doing so we're going to see
what's going to happen with totally
agree pat for the last six months the
crypto guys could
sit back and be like i told you so but
for the last week or two
the people you know the peter shifts of
the world who are like no way this is
crazy this is too volatile
this is uh speculative speculative yep
they can kind of say i told you so um
quick shout out to
eddie 89 just gave 50 bucks he sent me a
message saying man i want to give you i
want you to
wish a happy birthday to my friend
george from australia
for sunday from rameen edgar and sargon
hey
pbd my man happy birthday to you
george i wish you nothing but the very
best anyway so let's talk about some
ufos you okay with that oh my god let's
talk about some ufos because
it's been uh tom was begging he says pat
we have to talk about ufos
and uh so let's get right into it so
here we go
ufos as in us and explanate
owes us an explanation ufo
uh yeah an explanation i see what they
did tom twister right there
and you know who did that that's tom
zenner did that oh senator marco rubio
senator marco rubio told 60 minutes the
ufo is real and
the pentagon needs to investigate this
is the vt post story sunday night
florida senator marco rubio went on 60
minutes and said there have been enough
credible sightings lately to warn
some explanations and a full-fledged
investigation by congress rubio is the
head of the senate
intelligence committee so not only is he
privy to classified info what's going on
he is also in a position to help do
something to try to figure out
what these space vessels are going are
doing here the point rubio made on 60
minutes
was tases flying objects
are a serious risk to national security
rubio demanded that the pentagon prepare
a report on what they know about the
ufos and report
should be available within a month
anyways did you guys see the video the
other day like a bunch of videos coming
out and pilot's saying look i don't want
to talk about it i'm not somebody who
wants to go on television
but i tell you we've some weird we've
seen some weird things out there
where are you at with ufo's time you and
i have never had this conversation
before you got blasted up to space and
the aliens uh did the probe to you what
were your first thoughts
no
[Laughter]
speaking of ufos i got to get a chance
to caroline this tea is out of this
world
really thank you there you go i
appreciate that respect that's very nice
ufos and out of this world very good
so you can see what i did there all
right tell us about the probe go ahead
she did
the um no no no this is crazy it's like
reminds me of a sound
we're joking we're messing with this
south park episode where cartman ended
up with a satellite dish coming out of
his butt remember that
i think something bad happened up there
to me um
all right tomorrow but here's here's
what i think
there are too many videos out there that
are
um really credible the navy guys in
san diego and you've got the pilots you
have the courting of the pilots talking
and there was something going on down
there they talked about the tic tac
there was a tic tac shape
and it just disappeared went under water
yeah or something yeah and they
they saw actually saw a surface
disturbance you know so i i
you know i don't know do you believe in
ufos or no
that's true everybody wants to know this
does the biz doc believe in uf forces
you're going to do a case study on your
phone
i don't think i believe in like these
elaborate civilizations are living under
the crest of the earth no um
or living in underwater but i believe
that there's something out there
that's moving moving pretty quickly and
there's some sort of phenomena
and is it defense phenomena and one part
of the defense
you know isn't talking to the other part
of the defense department about what
they're doing
i don't know i think it's um i think
it's a little creepy and
you know i can't explain what i've seen
and you've got so many videos that it's
not guys at home using
you know final cut pro to make something
really kind of weird and interesting
you know i mean they're showing it on
today on history channel on fox on cnn
on msnbc
that this this this thing goes up boom
goes underwater boom boom boom just
moving really quick so
so yeah someday they interviewed a guy
who was with the cia he says
we're not saying it is a ufo we're not
saying that it is rap
yeah we're not we're not saying we're
not against ufos all we're saying is
we it may even be something used by our
enemies it could be russia it could be
china they don't know what it is all i'm
asking you tom
you specifically you this is on the
record your kids are watching right now
yes brooke and bailey are in school
they're different experiences to watch
on the podcast here right now that would
happen
that would happen so do you believe
somewhere out there
there's ufos i believe there are ufos
but i'm not
i don't believe in some other
civilization someplace you don't so you
don't believe there's a
there's a there's an exactly duplicate
of earth
somewhere else out there in the space
well if there is i want to go find the
me that's out there and ask him if he's
in trouble with his wife too
so wow how about you
no i'm not no no on civilizations but
yes that there's phenomenas and these
things are flying here's there's
something real
here's what i trust in okay here's what
i trust in here's what i trust in okay
i trust in math and what i mean by math
is the fact that
if math tells us
how much stuff is out there that we
haven't yet done research on
math is probably leaning towards the
fact that there's probably civilization
out there
there's probably aliens out there math
i'm a math guy math is leaning towards
there's got to be something out there
what that is i have no idea but there's
definitely got to be something out there
if you think about math
so you know how underwater you ever seen
a movie megalodon i don't know if you
ever seen the movie
yeah the ridiculous shark so what's more
real you believe more a megalodon exists
or ufos exist
megalodons megalodons are ufos if you're
listening to this today though today
not not years ago megalodon today do we
have a megalodon today
yes or do we have ufos today no i don't
think so i don't think there's a loch
ness monster i don't think there's a
megalodon
you don't believe there's a megalodon no
not down there you believe there's more
than an
alien yes do you believe there's a
megalodon
yes if you believe there's a megalith
sam doesn't kai
is there a megalodon
well in norway there's some sort of
creatures like that i don't know if
specifically
i'm talking megalodon like a gigantic
bigger than one of these whale sharks
that's
could eat a whale shark if it wanted to
it's massive
60 feet 100 feet i think that's more
likely than aliens coming up
at the depths of the oceans i wouldn't
underestimate it
so you think there's more are you going
with you think there's more you're a
math guy so what's the math on this well
it's a lot easier to go a few miles
underwater
than it is to go millions of miles in
space which means
if we have a few thousand miles to go
under water whatever couple
you know uh down how deep is the deepest
part of the ocean
the marianas trench is the deepest part
of it how deep is that i thought it was
like the inverse of everest
kai looked this up i thought it was like
35 000 feet the exact inverse of everest
so
by the way it's pitch black down there
sure it is the fish even got like
kai help me light bulbs coming off their
head the deepest marianas trench
deeper than the abyss how deep is it
2500 kilometers in length
69. there it is one minus 36. yeah i
thought it was pretty damn deep
yeah and how big is 11 000 meters deep
yeah
36 000 feet what what tom what is that
in my in miles
well mile is 50 280 so it's almost it's
closing in on seven miles
seven miles deep okay so here's the
thing just think about it okay now go
and see how deep is the space like how
far can the space go
you know that's the point so so if
there's space how far is the
atmosphere of the um how much does
how much ocean has been discovered okay
let's hear that unexplored yeah
approximately five percent of the ocean
has been discovered
95 percent of the ocean okay i get it
but that's ridiculous okay now go look
at do the same thing with space 99.99
okay so you're basically saying you
believe in aliens versus the megalodon
no what i'm trying to say
is it's a lot easier to find out if we
have a megalodon because you're dealing
with
whatever few miles versus it's
mathematically very can you pull it up
guy or no well
it's mathematically
challenging to find out what is in space
that's infinity how do you find that
infinity you can't so
i'm going to say i'm going to lean
towards only we're going to explore
roughly five percent of
the ocean yeah and then we've explored
an
infinitely smaller percentage of space
so i'm going to say there's more
likelihood to be aliens than i met with
them that's what i'm banking okay
what are the odds in vegas by the way
what are the odds in vegas is vegas
saying megalodon i think you just did it
right here you've got this
do you know yeah okay so to me i think
uh you know
i think there are some ufos out there i
i don't know what's going to happen
i have some thoughts on this say it go
ahead fos okay so number one
why every time that they see
okay remember i think it's important to
identi to establish that a ufo is an
unidentified
flying object just because it's a ufo
doesn't mean it's an alien it's just
something that they don't
know what it is it's unidentified it
could be a drone it could be
a plane it could be a hot air balloon it
could be you know
a megalodon that's flying who knows
what's going on it's a ufo it's
unidentified
number two why every time that there's
quote unquote footage of this stuff it
looks like
you know your nanny cam that's in your
baby's bedroom that it you can
10 years ago why is it always something
you can so there was one pilot who said
yeah i went up there
every day i saw something every day this
was a big
60 minute so you went up there every day
you saw a ufo you didn't want to bring a
dope camera with you
you didn't want to let anybody know you
just kind of kept this your little
secret every day
no i don't know and then the last thing
how i know for a fact there's no aliens
there's no ufos because when you become
president united states they tell you
all the secrets
yeah give it up and you know if they
told trump there's some aliens that
mother sucker is telling people
oh i know there's alien he can't keep a
secret first of all so i really believe
that
yes do you no no no i really believe
that he's gonna just
no run his mouth you know what the other
day i had uh i had a uh
i had a mike baker on okay mike baker is
a former cia agent this innova is going
to go live here soon
we had a good conversation together you
know what i asked him i said how long
does a ci agent a ci agent
so it depends 24 years 40 years sure how
long is the president or president
four years maybe eight years if you're
fdr maybe you know 16 years 13 years
right
not anymore but yeah anymore but you
know what i'm saying is four to eight
years but a ci agent 20 30 years i said
do you think when the president becomes
a president
they tell him everything do you think
the person that knows everything about
everything that's ever happened in the
history of america that's kept secret
say
you know area 515 area 51 you think
they will tell the president everything
i don't believe that
i don't believe you're a person sitting
here
you've been doing it for 32 years you
know stuff that
99.999 percent of the world doesn't know
and you get a new guy
who was an entrepreneur a one-term
senator a guy
that likes to rub people's back okay who
becomes a president a guy that
is a smooth talker from arkansas
a guy that's you know very what's wrong
with arkansas yeah what's we're saying
that they don't tell the president you
think they're gonna tell the president
everybody i suppose that there's close
to it
let me ask you a question what is the
track record of any president that's
been able to keep
every secret to themselves what's the
track record of a president who's
extremely ambitious
who's extremely competitive to reveal an
information to him that's
he's going to be able to keep it to
himself you don't think a president is
going to sit there and say let me tell
you what i just found out today
i was just in area 51. dude i saw
three-headed ufo it was
ridiculous i took a picture check this
out i told the guy take a picture i'll
take a picture with you so he took a
picture with you
you're taking selfies with aliens i
don't think i don't think presidents
know everything i'm telling you i don't
think presidents know everything i don't
know who the person i asked the guy said
who is the person that knows everything
he says i don't know there's god
i would say that's pretty true because i
couldn't even keep everything from
hillary someone was always telling her
stuff that's right
i was in hot water all the time clinton
ago i thought that was actually pretty
good
my guy i'm a clinton guy that's right so
so yeah i don't i don't know i don't
know
i don't know if they told trump
everything you think they told trump
everything can you imagine well
if they did that secret to being the
best no way in the world
they say everything okay there is no way
in the world you think trump would have
used the information he knew to threaten
them
let's uh hey look you know there's this
has been going back
since kennedy and you know we'll stay
away from conspiracies and stuff
but jfk said that he was very concerned
about the clandestine side of the cia
because it was this inherently
super-secret part of the us government
that was set aside from congress and it
was set aside from the
president it was set aside from senate
senate declares war congress makes
budget
president leads a nation with vision and
you know certain legislative agendas
with it and so he was pointing out here
we are this is the
checks and balances the bicameral system
of government
and we have a supreme court to help keep
us all honest when the big arguments
break out
meanwhile over here on the other side of
the defense department you've got the
clandestine
cia and it was jfk that said this is bad
and so i i'm with pat not only do they
not tell the president
they don't tell them anything they don't
tell themselves i don't think it's a
good strategy to tell the president
i don't think so either i don't think
it's to me you you know no
i'm backing you up and you're saying jfk
when i talk to jonah
he thought it was dangerous by the way
somebody said trump started star force
let me give credit to the person
i'd love to get our audience no this guy
wrote star force he said okay didn't
trump create star forces
yeah but okay go ahead sorry yeah if
you're if you're listening i'm actually
curious
go ahead adam i'm curious i want to see
what our audience have to say do they
believe in aliens or
or or not yeah if you believe aliens
exist
press thumbs up if you think they don't
press thumbs down like let's just say if
you're part of the megalodon community
put thumbs down
if you're part of the ufo community put
thumbs up but here's a question i'm
talking to chief disguise officer
jonah mendez okay and what jonah mendes
did is she would make
a mask looking like you and walking and
sitting right next to president bush
and president bush would think adam is
in and it looks identical to you
and there's even a picture of her doing
a mask of who a mask of anybody's face
prosthetics
she did she was the chief disguise
officer of the cia that was her job what
a job to have
exactly wow 28 years her and her husband
by the way okay
the role play they had going on i said
do you guys even trust each other if
you're married to each other he's 32
years you're 28 years old
exactly that's what it could be that uh
paulina
porter closer and i heard anything
tonight can you be that girl
so i asked the question i asked the
question i said so here's a question for
you says what's that
what what's the qual what's the what are
the great qualities of a ci agent
greatest ci agent ever what are great
qualities of a cia agent he said she
said it's very simple
very charming great sales people wow
incredible with people they know how to
get you to like them
you'll love them they're extremely
ambitious but there's one thing they
have
that the rest of the world doesn't have
i said what's that
when they discover what osama bin laden
did and they saved the world
when they go get intel from russia or
china
and it was because of them that they
saved the world they don't need any
recognition they're not looking for
glory
they don't need any rights yeah that's
what
made a great ci agent because they don't
go and say hey babe you won't even
believe what i did tonight so you know
the scanning of osama let me
we met an osama the other day two nights
ago three nights ago if you remember
that right so yeah yeah
you know you know this kind of osama
yeah so i kind of stopped the whole
thing tonight no you did like imagine
you made a girl at the bar
so what do you do for a living i work at
uh this accounting firm i'm one of the
accountants there how about yourself
what do you do
i kind of took out this kind of osama
that's right land a helicopter in his
backyard walked upstairs aired him out
what do you do
that's a problem for you yeah i mean
just tag me in a photo i don't care what
you say i got it
that's all i need tag me in the photo so
but that's very interesting yeah so the
point i'm trying to make to you is
what is a president's dna a president
wants what
they want recognition they need votes
recognition
i think the opposite why would you tell
the president
everything you shouldn't i wanted to be
a guy you ever met these guys that you
talk to
and they don't say nothing but they
remember everything you say they'll sit
in a room and they'll just go boom
you'll never catch them do something
like this
they never do this they're just they're
just focused and they're like they're
looking at everybody like this
they don't block what is the matter with
this guy right but their computer right
here
okay you said that no problem got it
what does this guy say good got it
still two hours later now one word has
come out they're the smartest person in
the room
right that guy those people weirded me
out that's the guy
that needs to know everything that's the
guy that works for the cia for 33 years
that has
no aspirations of being a comey no
aspirations on being on tv no
aspirations of doing anything like that
that's the person what motivates that
type of person no it's a dna it's a
wiring it's not about motivation it's
just i
it is who i am it's a wiring there's not
you like
no one can make you be like that i can't
make
herbie like that him be like that tommy
like that you're either like that or
you're not like that it's purely your
dna part so
all this stuff you read about what the
president the day you get you know
voted in they tell you everything they
don't tell you okay i stand corrected
this is not disney's book of secrets
yeah i don't know about it they go to
that little
leather book up so if you are the
president you're gonna say dude just let
me know right now there's aliens and
there's no aliens i gotta know
you're gonna wanna you're gonna ask that
question sorry we can't tell you i'm
sorry didn't obama say that didn't he
you got an obama number no bush bush got
an interview with the jimmy kimmel
and jimmy kimmel asked this week obama
said something about it right didn't he
said something about what efos he said
something about trump this week in a
book i don't know if you saw that
he said uh yeah
do we have that as a story or no can you
put that up obama
trump book uh uh no but bush was being
interviewed by kimmel
and kimmel ask him a question says so so
let me ask you a question when you
become a president
do they take you into area 51 and tell
you all the dark secrets jfk all that
stuff what happened he says yes
are you willing to reveal any of it with
us no
so he did say that he said yes and then
he said no okay so
what was all that no secrets talk but
but do you really think you're gonna
tell them
everything do you really think they're
gonna tell the president
do you think that's a good business
strategy play a game let's play a game
yeah
well bush could just walk down the hall
talk to his dad back then when his dad
was alive
but for many years it's like hey dad you
know did you really install
chimpanzees the president of honduras
yeah but that was just for fun that was
just kind of a weird weekend thing with
the cia
you know he says dad's going to tell him
everything go ahead the old daddy
approached go ahead you were gonna say
let's say you become president
pbd president pbd yeah all right
hypothetical
you're elected you're a two-term
president beloved
you're telling me that you wouldn't go
into area 51 you wouldn't go into the
cia and say i want to know about this
tell me this you wouldn't ask is what
i'm saying oh there there's
no way in the world i'm not asking i
never i've never told you i'm not asking
but i'm
saying they might not tell you i am
telling you it's not a good business
model to tell
it the only people that ought to know
the only people that ought to know is
not our kind of regimes
it's a regime like uk britain that the
same person is going to lead for 40
years
30 years not our model with the high
turnover the attrition
here's here's why not our model you want
a guy to know something
who leaves the next guy comes and
trashes him for eight years
hurts his legacy and that guy is going
to go and use that against the other
politicians inside to say
i swear to god if he says anything i'm
going to disclose this information
you don't think that kind of
negotiations happens behind closed doors
no you there's certain
volatility there's no way in the world
it's a good strategy to tell presidents
everything no it's just correct and
remember we all the first week of any
presidency is retaliation
politics right what is every new
president for the last
four new presidents and it's not a
republican or democrat thing we've had
two democrats two republicans right
what do they do they issue executive
orders and then we're all looking at cnn
saying how many executive orders did
biden issue versus trump versus obama
versus bush
and all these executive orders come out
which is basically undo this undo that
undo this redo this prohibit this enable
this
and the executive orders are flying off
the shelves and so that the first move
is to use the executive order to bypass
legislative process on both sides
so you have retaliation politics and
stuff i'm with pat
you don't tell those cats a lot of this
stuff because it's an impulsive
attention-based world yeah you know
what's really interesting
hollywood did a reasonable job with it
there's a great book out called charlie
wilson's war
about about about the true story wasn't
it a movie
yeah i think tom hanks was in there yeah
and uh julia roberts it's a great story
hollywood did it was it was an
entertaining hollywood movie and
but the book clearly showed and there's
a lot of people that commented on the
book that said no this is the way it
happens
so watch the movie with some popcorn
enjoy it folks but then go read the book
and you understand what the clandestine
services group of our government is all
about
and you know i thought it was very
interesting that a lot of people weighed
in and said hey this book
was written by charlie wilson yeah yeah
yeah but there's a bunch of things in
here that are very accurate for the way
that um groups within your government
have congressional hearings and do
secret
stuff and so i i don't want the new
president to know everything
there's a lot of stuff that yeah it's a
risk empty you don't want that you don't
by the way 130 people believe 130 people
press thumbs up
versus 11. so your megalodon community
it's 11 the ufo community 130. so that
many people believe that you've been
watching
meg too many times with jason's stadium
i think that you just take off one week
and uh go back to your comments
go back to your usual uh so let's talk
about the story this whole thing with
michael
okay can i say last thing yeah go
forward that just shows how desensitized
we are
oh breaking news there's aliens all
right cool like did you check out my
latest instagram post though
like that's how desensitized we are to
aliens
oh yeah they're they're there's aliens
what's they were here would be
desensitized meaning yeah it's here it's
a part of it i believe in aliens they
were here there's ufos it's no big deal
all right cool what's up did you what's
on tv tonight
you see what happened in lakers game
yeah aliens where where you think it
ought to be
on everybody's aliens this is a this is
a sort of a bigger deal than what
happened in the lakers game last night
in my opinion what a direct call out you
freaking guys
yeah i was telling you i was more
important than a lakers highlight yeah
last night yeah
shame on you the basketball community is
very disappointed in you right now
anyway it's going back to so if you are
it sounds like you're a little bit
worried right now i'm getting a feeling
that you're a little bit concerned
about the aliens yeah maybe life is
going to be safe or not for you is there
is there
just yeah elementary school how
desensitized okay so you're talking
about more desensitized
it's going to be all right dad and we're
going to figure this thing out yeah
so this story of guardian u.s officials
confirms 130 incidents of mysterious
havana syndrome brain if we can flip it
so people can see the article as well
so if you want to go a little high u.s
diplomats spies and defense officials
have reported serious symptoms
and some within the past few weeks there
are more than 330 incidents of
unexplained brain
injury known as havana syndrome among
u.s diplomats spies and defense
officials
some of them within the past few weeks
it has been reported the new york times
said three cia officers had been
had reported serious symptoms since
december following overseas assignments
requiring outpatient treatment at the
walter reed military hospital in
washington
one episode was within the last two
weeks the reported number of cases is
about 70 more than
have previously been acknowledged mark
zedd who represents
some former uh official afflicted by
havana syndrome said he had been con
contracted by
more people who believed they had been
affected by the numbers
are definitely increasing he said the
u.s officials confirmed that there are
continue to be fresh cases under review
that have cautioned
that the publicity given to previous
savannah syndrome kids are okay
so go to the lord to see what else is
down there and anything and then down
there's the go-go little lord the
evidence for microwave effects
of the type of categorized havana
syndrome is exceedingly weak
rolfer wrote a foreign policy no
proponent of the idea has outlined how
the weapon
would actually work no evidence has been
offered that a such a weapon has been
developed by any nation extraordinary
claims
required extraordinary evidence and no
evidence has been offered to support the
existence of
this mysterious weapon okay interesting
you think these weapons are being used
tom so there's two things in this
article here
one is you've got a bunch of very
professional people being
examined at walter reed by some very
good doctors that say something
definitely happened to me
the second half of this article is the
evidence for a microwave weapon is not
there
so okay so maybe it's not a microwave
weapon but the point is there's
something going on that is a different
form
of of device or technology or maybe it's
just
you know the um remember the uh can i
pull up the fox news story you had a
couple guys in russia
that died when you know kgb operatives
just sprayed them with uh
you know polonium plutonium that's um
atomized and gave them radiation
sickness and killed them
over time so these folks are talking
about havana syndrome
i think there's people there that are
really sick i think it's not a
coincidence that it happened at a
government building
is it a microwave weapon i don't know
but these people got really really sick
and i think there's advancing
technologies out there in the spy
community
to kind of neutralize each other why is
it called the havana syndrome
because it was at the the u.s
um was it the embassy outpost or the
intelligence building
in cuba in cuba havana is in cuba which
is south of the u.s it's been there
right which is you ever been to south
america i've never no i've not been
there okay
stand corrected how far is that key west
from
90 miles there you go welcome to florida
the republic
took the picture republican and
democratic lawmakers are demanding
answers about who is responsible for
growing
consensus of experts believed our target
attacks on u.s diplomats kai can you pay
attention to pull that out please
uh and national security officials using
pulse microwave energy that many now
believe was used as a weapon to harm
american citizens
in december 2017 i made uh which now is
kind of the fateful trip to moscow
explain
mark uh a 26-year-old veteran of the cia
who was forced to retire as a cia's
official
for clandestine operations in europe
after suffering a mysterious traumatic
brain injury and debilitating side
effects
following a trip to moscow in 2017 go a
little lower to see what else he says
keep going keep going i woke up in the
middle of the night with an incredible
uh a case of vertigo of uh 10
10 what is that how do you pronounce
that tom tinnitus tonight is ringing in
years
which is ringing in the ears i was
falling over i was nauseated
there was no mistake that something
really really terrifying happened that
night in moscow i had been in
afghanistan i spent some time in
iraq the this was the most terrifying
experience of my life
okay and it go up see if he says
anything else as you go lower the sieve
evidence was a
marriott near hotel when he was attacked
this case of some of the symptoms
described by 40 diplomats in havana
serving at the u.s embassy and dozens of
u.s diplomats serving in china who in
2016 began experiencing
extreme vertical nausea sometimes
followed by a loud piercing sound that
experts now believe was a result of
directed
radio frequency energy in the form of
microwave
and by the way this is not a republican
thing or a democratic thing both cnn and
fox were talking about it
and both democrats and republicans are
saying can we look into
this i think uh there's three main
points here
just to to break this down number one is
russia shady
yes number two does russia do things to
poison people
and do havana like syndrome episodes
yes number three remember the i remember
in the 80s my mom would say don't stand
in front of the microwave
boom that's the final thing maybe you
shouldn't stand in front of the
microwave i don't know how this is
happening
but you put your cup of coffee in there
you keep it moving you show you know
like for instance
and they're all mounted above your other
friend close to your head my friend
caroline just warmed up this tea i don't
know i'm not feeling so good right now
but
hopefully we're all right maybe she did
a service but i think isn't the point
here russia does some shady ass [ __ ]
and everything all right you know
anything is that what like this ass
stands for
yeah exactly method of uh
weapons have changed dramatically man
like the days of uh you know
when i was speaking to uh mike baker as
a mike how do you change this up he said
change the method of a military budget
that we have we're spending too much
money on weapons that you're not going
to use for war you're just not going to
use for war we have to spend more money
of our budget say trillion dollars of
our budget needs to be spent towards
like uh uh bio warfare intelligence
learning about these types of attacks
that are happening you know the
cyber warfare we're not prepared for
that that's kind of what he was talking
about so
i don't know it's it makes you maybe
fund a lab in wuhan that could
work on a virus it could be oh you see
what he did there okay
you said you just 11 minutes ago said
conspiracy jfk and you went to a
different direction and you just dropped
something like that
you went no no no it is conspiracy but
the point is have you been to one
i have not been about no i've been in
havana not foreign
i love the wet market have you ever had
raw chipmunk man tasty
the um no the point is
let's assume there's no lab in wuhan and
nothing like there but the point is
do you think governments have labs that
are experimenting with biological agents
that could
debilitate arguments do you think u.s
yes i think they all do i think
everybody is i think they're all playing
in these new realms exactly what pat
says
you know another aircraft carrier
another battleship another
you know nuclear rocket that's not going
to be launched oh god we hope
uh but then what are they doing on the
other side you know how do you handle
big populations
poisons biological agents you know
interference with power grids
i mean and that's the other thing what
are they investing in they're investing
things that don't make people sick
but they're looking at things how do we
hack in and shut down power grids
and like somebody has hacked in and shut
down part of a gasoline operation
system that disrupted part of the east
coast in the united states for uh
energy transport yep that's real i think
you hit the nail on the head pat that
you know things have changed so warfare
will need to change
rather than tanks maybe you need
microwaves or biological warfare
things have changed significantly since
you were in the army yeah dramatically
oh yeah dramatically i think uh one
investing what
what direction you make your investments
in but also realizing that as you get
bigger
you may not even know like a 17 year old
hacker may be an enemy of yours
it's who you offend right now and you
got to be so careful with who you offend
right now there are so many
though you may be a 40 year old guy
who's done well for yourself financially
you could offend the wrong person that
knows certain ways to hack into certain
things and makes your life a living hell
it's a completely different ballgame
today
so it's not just russia or china
the war many people may be playing as a
different war than the government may be
playing it's a complete different game
today
well very very different game being
played today with that being said
um it's like that's like let me put it
through this way let me put it through
this way
say you know how to do jiu jitsu
unboxing mma we go in the street fight
you can 99.9 percent of people they go
out a guy comes up to you at the bar
pushes you punches you in the face you
drop him and next thing he's on the
floor crying and you take out three of
his friends
that makes good for a good video goes
viral on youtube takes off right
but say you do that to an 18 year old
kid and you talk trash to him and you're
the ufc mma guy you know how to fight
that guy ends up following you he finds
out who you are he finds details about
you
and he makes your life a living hell and
you're wondering what the hell happened
the ufc the jiu jitsu stuff doesn't
matter today just like
tanks weapons m16s f
these things don't matter with today's
war it's
just the reality of it it's a very
low-key china method of attacking versus
the look how powerful we are attacking
it's very different dana white would be
very upset to hear that
it's just the truth though yeah it's
very but here's the thing who the hell
is going to buy pay-per-view of two
hackers going
going out against each other hello you
know
17 year old from you know toledo's well
pat you should apologize to the hackers
right now
i'd like on behalf of this oh you're
right you're right
don't look at us we're nice people check
this out i have your best interest in
mind going back to what i was talking
about charlie wilson's war
you know they figured out one thing the
afghans did not have better technology
than the russians or russians did but
they figured out one thing if we could
give them
basic stinger all stinger is a simple
little
you know missile you know you might call
it a bazooka but
it was just a missile and it shot down
helicopters and airplanes so it was very
it was not huge secret super
star wars spy tech it was just let's
just give them an ability to
hide behind the rocks because they
didn't march around in big groups or big
battalions like the russians did
so five afghans could be behind a rock
and knock down a helicopter and that's
how they eventually
chased russia out of it it was low-tech
and
it was asymmetrical you fight this way
we fight this way so it's asymmetrical
and now it's a digital war it's an
economic war
there the war is being fought so
differently
it's it's not about war armaments and
actually if we break into a conventional
giant conventional bombing and assault
war it's really
you're stepping backwards with somebody
that's not the way
the next war be fought if it happens to
be china i don't disagree by the way
caleb box maybe
maybe with my guy maybe i wouldn't have
caleb he just gave 50 bucks and he said
if there's another atom in the galaxy we
are all doomed that's
oh caleb yeah he said that about you
okay remember that caleb
okay so next conversation next topic is
yes
we can't hear you buddy turn on that's
that's kai's buddy by the way
one thing that i think is interesting as
well as as war now
it's not nations against nations it
could be one
rogue osama bin laden versus a country
or this and the other
and also even going back to the korean
war
is in some ways you can win by just not
losing or just not giving up like the
north korea
did uh and vietnam as well where they
didn't win they just tired out
to where america then lost interest in
the war and that led to america losing
so
there's different ways of winning wars
and especially now when it's not a whole
nation versus a whole nation
it's a lot different you got to give a
shout out to kai i mean the guy
for fun reads you know teddy roosevelt
books and winston churchill books this
is where he's getting this stuff from
easy
he's a strategist so thank you
general lude bank of america
will raise its minimum wage to 25 bucks
an hour by 2025.
okay bank of america folks if you're
looking for a job by 2025 bank of
america has given 25
an hour jobs which 25 bucks an hour is a
50 000 a year salary okay
so let's read this bank of america said
tuesday that it will raise a
hourly minimum wage of its employees by
2025 to 25 bucks an hour it costs
us a few hundred million dollars a year
but it's an investment the bank ceo
brian said
it's not the first time bank of america
has raised its minimum wage for its
employees in 2017 the bank raised its
minimum wage to 15 bucks an hour
two years later the company announced it
would lift all uh
the that level to 20 bucks an hour for
the upcoming two years and so did the
schedule now be in
uh with an increase that impacted more
than 200 000 workers last month biden
signed an executive order lifting
minimum wage for federal contractors
workers to 15 bucks an hour in early
2022 from the current level of 1095
meanwhile other banks are also raising
wages all by not as aggressively
jp morgan chase announced 2018 that it
would increase his minimum wage from 15
bucks 20 bucks an hour for 22 000
employees
depending on their local cost of living
citigroup raises minimum wage from 15
bucks an hour at 250 bucks an hour in
2019. so
25 bucks an hour is bank of america
really raising their minimum wage to 25
bucks an hour or tom are they saying
we just want better pool of talent that
we're paying for
we're willing to pay 50 000 an hour
because 50 000
a year because at fifty thousand dollars
here we're going to get a four-year
degree we're gonna get
experience we're gonna get this we're
gonna get that and uh is this a good
marketing campaign tom for b of a i
think it's a populist marketing campaign
around the
simple phrase 25 dollars um however
what you're what you accurately point
out is that
there will be talent competing for those
jobs and by the way in 20 by 2025
you know the the number of humans that
are in you know
bank individual branches down the street
is dropping
you know there's so much all banking is
being automated so much is done online
i mean you know you you take a look at
that operation goes lower because yeah
so these are going to people and this is
going to be people in headsets and call
centers
because the corner branches i mean
they're harder and harder to find thanks
that's actually a very good question can
we ask a question here when's the last
time you went to a branch
um last time i went to a branch it was
i i i was forced to and what i was
forced to
gun through your head no no kim and i
ran probably no no kim and i made a
transaction and they
had to have a bank check so i had to go
in and get a cashier's check and then
fedex six months how many times have you
been in that's a better question
zero okay so zero last six months if i
didn't have to be going and get a
cashier's check
because we had a large transaction i
wouldn't have gone in about yourself
all my needs would take money maybe once
a quarter how many how many
last six months have you been in the
branch caroline
zero not even once sam maybe once
nothing once zero kai i mean okay we
can't hear you guy
we can't hear you kai i'm turned on go
ahead uh get it together kai
what's going on over there buddy
generally my bank doesn't even have a
branch here so
damn i don't even have my bank don't
even have branches that's how good my
bank is
okay ultimately let me ask let me ask
the audience the first time you see
helsinki federal you'll know that
if you're watching this when in the last
six months how many times have you
walked into a branch at a bank i'm
actually curious
comment we're watching your comments go
ahead adam go ahead uh tom
no so i think this is basically i think
this is going to be call centers and
basic processors in these layers
yep and 50k minimum they're not a bad
gift it's probably going to be a job
there's going to be a lot of people
competing for those fifty thousand
dollars
here's what we did if you remember just
uh uh five and a half years ago we're in
texas and
we're going through hiring people and
text minimum wage at 7 20. one day i sat
there and i said guys we're not doing
this anymore
moving forward we're hiring 15 bucks an
hour we started 15 bucks an hour and the
quality went
in a better direction so it's not you're
increasing your minimum wage
to me it's what you're saying is we are
willing to pay
more money for better employees by the
way
to the people of the minimum wage
community be of a
what bfa did to the minimum wage
community
said whether you like to increase the
minimum wage or not we don't care what
you think
we are willing to pay more for better
talent
so the market has to compete to get
these jobs
and then the market has to improve to
keep these jobs
viva is not saying uh your minimum wage
is going to be this much number is
saying
we're only looking at hiring people that
are worth 50 000 or more that's what
they're saying that's correct if you are
not worth 50 000
or more we're not hiring you that's what
they're saying but the interpretation
and the way you sell the story it's kind
of like
you know it's a 25 minimum wage america
maybe at 15 but we're going to be at 25
minimum wage great marketing but i think
b of a smart
it's going to cost 100 million bucks
what's 100 million a few hundred million
dollars to b of a
nothing they make billions on top of
billions on interest
adam any thoughts on your end yeah i
think this is comes down to what one of
your favorite words ever which is
competition so they're competing with
the chases of the world
and the wells fargos of the world and um
and the city groups of the world
and they're basically drawing a line in
the senate and saying we're better we'll
pay more
we're looking for better talent and i
think something that it's
very important to point out minimum wage
minimum wage minimum wage talk about
this
what are the key words in this wage
obviously your pay and minimum
absolute lowest bottom of the barrel
minimum
you get the minimum pay you get the
minimum effort absolute minimum
something that i've come to recognize
since being with valuetainment for the
last year or so
is that minimum wage the whole fact that
it's a it's it's actually [ __ ]
it's how wait a minute yeah what did you
just i went there i went there
watch your language i'm trying am i
trying my best but my gosh soy boy on
fire
the fact that that 725 is an absolute
minimum
yeah who the hell is taking that job
like you're either a high school kid or
you
are lucky to even be in this country or
you're just willing to accept the
absolute minimum because your skill set
is less than desirable let's say so the
fact that
this is definitely something you know
you you would hear
um this is an evolution of of thought
minimum wage they should be paying more
corporations be paying more they should
pay their fair share that's not how well
this comes down to the individual
if you're 40 years old and you're still
somehow making minimum wage dude what
are you doing with your life
right so this is more about the
individual recognizing totally agree
i'm better than this yep they're only
paying minimum wage i guess that's what
they're paying
yeah what kind of a loser are you right
yeah
yeah i'm fired up it's microwavable by
the way yes microwavable tea just got me
yesterday yesterday i'm at love so two
days ago i'm at loves with jen
we're eating our loves this guy stops by
range rover nice looking raindrop i
think his name was
jeremy i think i mean maybe j was with
jay gave me his business card says man i
love the podcast i'm watching all the
podcasts i'm watching all your stuff
love the fact that you're in uh
uh uh uh what do you call i'm a boca
and we're glad to have you here all this
other stuff and i said great he says
by the way it's great also watching a
podcast with adam i said tell me why it
says because i've watched all the
episodes and i've seen adam changed over
the last 60 episodes
so people are seeing an evolution in our
buddy here adam sosnick
and we're working on adam potentially
one day running for governor in florida
in the next 20 years
probably not whoever charismatic
good-looking well-spoken
sense of humor and i don't need the
accolades behind
you with the right team behind you who
knows man governor sauce there you go
with pat behind you you can go anywhere
you can do anything but no i think
that's
that's an important thank you to quote
unquote jeremy you're recognizing that
i think that's something that we all
could recognize is that we're so
unless there's somebody pushing you and
asking you
all right well why would you think this
so why don't we do this it's interesting
you're saying this because just
yesterday
we're in my office we're going through
topics for podcasts right
i got two minutes before i have to jump
on a zoom okay and you bring up the
topic of abortion
oh my god i did not bring it up it's
kind of stories we have here right
because of abbot let me read it to you
caroline and then we're going to go
there this is when tom probably wants to
step out in a minute to get on his
flight
so governor abbott signs fetal heartbeat
bill banning most abortions in texas
this is usa today's story
he signed into law wednesday legislation
that prohibits abortion once a fetal
heartbeat is detected effectively
banning most abortions in the state the
restriction puts texas on the vanguard
among states challenging the boundaries
of
roe versus wade the 1973 landmark
supreme court case that established a
woman's legal right to abortion
there's not a specific time frame tied
to the restriction and fetal heartbeats
can be detected as early as six weeks
or six weeks from women's last menstrual
period not
since the start of her pregnancy
according to american congress of uh
uh gynecologist opponents of the law
argue that it will prohibit
abortions before most women are even
aware that they are pregnant effectively
outlaw the procedure it also does not
include exceptions in cases of rape or
incest
a caveat that has been long uh has long
been the standard in abortion law so
i read the story that we have on talking
about it today because of what abby's
doing in texas
all of a sudden you're like what is this
all about yeah i was fired up yeah you
were fired up
and then we got people walking in and
you know i gotta talk i gotta
what do you think i gotta zoom in 30
seconds i'm like that i'm not doing it
right now i gotta get on the zoom i'm
getting mentally prepared for zoom so
but you guys
leave yeah you go outside i hold
everybody my zoom lasts 30 minutes i
come out you guys are still having a
heater
oh yeah walk us through what happened
with your experience yesterday because i
know nothing about it what happened i
think this is something that
um the p the fine people of texas might
want to consider
uh is actually polling women and seeing
what they have to say
so i asked every female in the office
i did there's i don't know there's you
know eight to ten ladies that
responded you're a talent you're not an
employee yeah you're simply in talent
so you're just talking to people what
does that have to do with anything it
has to be a disclaimer hr
you're a talent yes yes speaking of
people hr did come up and
say this is probably a little
interesting because you're a talent
you're my talent i'm a talented guy baby
i'm asked a question so what happened
tell us
so i asked the ladies in the room ladies
what
should be the drop dead cutoff point
where an abortion
is acceptable meaning here we go okay so
because initially i i had a little
longer approach i said you know
i'm not going to reveal the number but i
said maybe
you know closer to five six months
however and they said well
crazy you're crazy so i started getting
women's feedback
pay attention governor abbott women's
feedback and the universal number
was first disclaimer a women women
have a right to do whatever they want
with their body and that's the the side
that i'm on this
so for a government especially
republicans who believe in
individual freedoms and keep the
government out of my life and keep them
out of my bedroom and
government shouldn't tell me what to do
but they're the ones basically
implementing this
six week regulatory
law mandate what have you the resounding
of the resounding answer from the women
here
in the in the audience was basically
three months that because within four to
six weeks you might not even know you're
pregnant
right that's the what women had to say
i've never been
had a period before although you know
some people might think i have
no you haven't but you often need might
all my friends yeah
so the point is uh and then i did some
research so i did the market research
with the women they said three months
and then
here's the difference here because
there's a mississippi there's a court
case that's being taken up in the
supreme court mississippi mississippi is
basically saying 15 weeks is when the
cutoff point should be
and there's actually something currently
in the supreme court
um precedent called fetal viability
where states may not
ban abortions before 22 weeks so that's
sort of the magic number
22 weeks okay people are asking where
are you going with this
people actually asking a question i'm
going that this is a a clear overreach
xm xms
this is a clear overreach by the state
of texas um
to attempt to outright ban
abortions and they're suggesting six
weeks
and last but not least this is the the
twist that i also found out
that you know the state officials want
to enforce this ban but
what they're enabling individuals to do
is file lawsuits
versus abortion providers doctors nurses
what have you
from individuals individuals can file
lawsuits
to basically um
have endless lawsuits harass harassing
lawsuits
coming from all different angles to
these abortion providers
rather than one major lawsuit where they
could use all their
resources to fight it so they want
basically all these lawsuits okay pull
up whatever coming in
email so i'm on the side of the ladies
i'm on the side of the
20 week suggestion i think this is
overreach from texas
tom i think
um yeah i think more deeply about
about this i don't want the government
legislating decisions on life and i'll
tell you why
you know you take a look at greece and
the netherlands
who have you know they're broke
excuse me they're broke and they can't
afford to care for the elderly and an
elderly person that has
no family around you know you you get to
this very slippery slope
where elderly people with no family
no financial support 85 years old
alzheimer's symptoms and they're like
well guess what we're done here and
you know you know state can you know
push the euthanasia button and i just
don't think the government
should be you know legislating life i
think it's a very slippery slope
i also happen to think that it's that
problem that we have i think is
civilization specifically america on the
the issue of of choice and abortion is
i don't think we love you know people
enough and i think that there's been a
you know a great failure that we've
arrived at a place where
out of a fear of responsibility the
ability to care and the ability to do
that
that we think the only way out is to
terminate and i think that's terrible
um i wish i wish as a people we had the
systems
and the support and everything i mean i
i listen to christian community talk
about abortion and they want to give the
you know hey let's just give her a car
seat and some diapers and stuff like
that wait a minute
this this this woman's got a single mom
got to raise that child all the way up
we need to have a whole set of services
that support her to help her
to do that and the child bearing thing
is
not on the men it's on the women they're
you know
they have the child and they're carrying
it so i i don't think government should
be
in these decisions and i think we've
really the
the church and the communities out there
have failed to really
put their effort where their mouth is
about if you're gonna say no abortions
you're gonna care for people
you know let me tell you the bible says
that religion that god our father finds
faultless is true is this
take care of widows and orphans in their
distress and i don't
see churches doing enough to do end to
end taking care of people so that we can
say if we've got this point of view
we're going to go end to end because
that's what god said god loves life god
wants this why aren't you going end to
end to help that single mom go all the
way up to high school
to help her have the resources to do
that so she can work and get care for
that child
no we say stop the abortion and we'll
legislate it on you
me i'll tell you my christian viewpoint
i believe god's the ordainer of life but
i'm not ready to step across the line
and draw boxes around people at their
moment of freedom when they're deciding
what to do
but i'll say as i sure as hell wish that
we as a civilization as a people and as
christians
we're going more end to end and not just
saying let's stop
abortion but let's start loving and
supporting people so they can get that
child
all the way to high school and support
that single mom because the dad's gone
a lot of times or if you want to pull up
there's a lot
in there and i'm sorry but i'm telling
you did you have a response
no i just think with something that's i
i i thank you for the heartfelt response
genuinely tom
that was that was that was deep i think
something that's pretty disgusting
is the fact that texas quote unquote
does not include exceptions in cases of
rape or incest and i know that that's
probably you know
maybe a percent or two percent of of
these types of situations it's not a big
deal
but i think that's disgusting not to
account for were you at the
uh meeting that dudley hosted 11 years
ago where they were showing how much it
cost
to test whether you're pregnant or not
because those machines are very very
expensive
he was talking about focusing on the
family donating machines
well we were raising money to buy a few
machines and each machine you know how
much each machine is
at the time fifty four thousand dollars
wow a machine to just go and make sure
like you go test it
to find out if you're pregnant or not as
opposed to just like a 1999 test at uh
walgreens yeah but the machine the
machine yeah of course but the machine
to kind of go and do uh
the real stuff the real stuff she's kind
of checking do you have an ectopic
pregnancy
are you healthy what's going on here
there's a lot of questions with that
this is part of i think health care
people machine that was like 54 000 and
the percentage that we're sharing that
most
uh individuals who are pregnant girls
who are pregnant they're afraid to go in
they're afraid to talk to somebody
they're embarrassed
so they just don't want to go out there
and talk to the doctor because what it
modifies it's a lot of different stats
too but
if you can pull the kai the one i sent
you the first one and then let's go to
the second one
so this is from gallup okay this is
gallup and it's recent go to the
date to see when this was given to us uh
uh i think it's 2021. okay go go up go
up because the dates go all the way up
to
2020 perfect so if you go all the way at
the top
uh this the second one or okay right
there right there right there
do you think abortion should be legal
under any circumstances legal only under
certain circumstances or illegal in
all circumstances right so look at the
colors if you can flip the screen so
people can see it
dark green is illegal only under certain
circumstances
green is legal under any grey is illegal
under uh illegal in all circumstances so
if you look at illegal it's 20 okay
that's 20 do you see it if you look at
it legal
under any circumstances 29 and if you
look at
legal under only certain circumstances
is
50 okay so i'm willing to bet the 20
is probably christian church going
they're probably
have certain problems they're pro-lifers
you got
the then you got the rest of the
percentage if you want to go up to see
historically
how much this has changed our opinion
over the years okay how much has changed
our opinions over the years go over here
there you go
so this is actually very interesting so
same exact thing
legal under any legal only under certain
illegal in all and i have no opinion
about it
so this is 2020 and it goes all the way
down if you look at in 2020 legal under
any is 29
go back 30 years go back 30 years let's
go to
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going look at 1989 still 29
percent keep going keep going keep going
keep going
what's all the way at the bottom of the
number that they have on there uh 1977
21 percent 1980 25 percent so it's not
moved it's not
moved that's the point so it's not
moving now 45 years
and by the way the one in the middle
also hasn't moved and illegal although
we go all the way to the top guy go all
the way to the top we were looking at
uh right there legal only under certain
hasn't moved illegal and all hasn't
moved no opinion people have gone to two
percent it used to be four percent
people had an opinion about it before
now uh
more people are having opinions about it
so this
hasn't really moved much in the last
40 years there's a group of people that
are staying on one side
there's a group of people that are
staying on another side some say
well the kid doesn't have a choice yet
it's got to be on the mother so the
priority becomes
mother chooses what to happen with the
baby some are saying well wait a minute
that's the baby you you should have
protected you know
safe sex you shouldn't have done
unprotected says if you're doing that
and you have your baby you should take
responsibility and raise the kid
that debate's gonna go on for a long
time scientifically if you say when it's
a heart
heartbeat six weeks man you can go
through it
so if it's saying hey when is the person
you know when is a baby really
a live heartbeat the numbers are numbers
if you want to go science so if they go
science if they go so the only thing
that a pro-choice argument has
is the woman has the right to abort
it's okay whether they want to abort the
live baby or not
it doesn't matter the argument lately
the last 10 years some politicians have
been pushing to say
36 weeks 38 weeks 40 weeks
even the day up you're hearing a lot of
those that's amazing that's extreme i'm
just telling you yeah so there is
extreme but
i think i think something that we i mean
the whole purpose of our show
is to eliminate the extremes on the left
and the right the eliminate the extreme
like for instance i don't want to name
names there was someone that we that had
the conversation yesterday
he said i think the woman should have
the baby no matter what rape incest i
don't care they need to have the baby
yeah he said that is extreme bro he goes
yeah i'm extreme
that's aggressive you're telling me if
your uncle rapes a 15-year-old
the fifth-year-old knee has to have the
baby that's absurd
but also at the same other extreme
you're a month out from
having the baby yeah you're eight months
pregnant you're considering aborting it
that is extreme
so it looks like 50 of the people said
it should be legal
under certain conditions and i think
that's the the reality in america today
final thoughts tom um people have got
this long-standing argument of when does
life begin
and what i want to know is why does
compassion stop
and so everybody wants the baby to be
born but where's the compassion
to to be if the society said
life is really valuable and if something
like this happens it's unfortunate
but we're going to support that mom
support that child get them through
school give them the best chance to go
then we don't need the laws because we
as a people would say wait a minute this
is terribly unfortunate maybe it was
careless maybe it was reckless maybe
it's irresponsible
okay but you've got this woman there
with the child we want the child to grow
up in such a way so that they
can have a fighting chance not to have a
encumbered
youth and maybe grow up in the wrong
kind of neighborhood wrong kind of
choices
you know where does compassion start i
don't care where life starts i want to
know where compassion starts
and why does compassion seem to end when
the child is born
because if we were a society that
thought that way and thought long term
and people have heard me use my upstream
downstream arguments if you don't want
to have
problems with poverty and a lot of
things happening downstream then you
need to go back upstream
and upstream is showing compassion and
finding ways to support
the single moms and the children and
give them a fighting chance through life
regardless of how that child came to be
and you don't need abortion laws because
people would say it's terrible it
happened to you and even
you know you really kind of did this
yourself that really wasn't responsible
but
society this is the way we feel and this
is how we're going to care this we're
going to do this because the greater
good
is to give that child and you an
opportunity to make
we have a we have a personal situation
going on that that
it's i'm not going to give the whole
information but it really bothers me
and uh you know it's
it's it's one of those things where
there's this kid
that i just don't like the situation
this kid is in it
totally bothers me totally and we've
been in this discussion about
what we want to do whether we want to
adopt this kid or not and the mom
wouldn't do it and the
person's mom wouldn't anyways we've been
going back and forth it's a very very
emotional conversation that we have
on one end you're hearing like how many
people were accidental babies
like i don't know if i was planned i
don't know if you were planned i don't
know if you were there were many kids
that were not planned it just kind of
happened there's a lot of people that
you know mom and dad weren't planning on
having at that time mom and dad were you
know
so how many of those people turned out
to do something big in their lives
what do you do with those stories but on
the flip side there's also people in
america that are having babies because
we pay 400
of benefit and welfare and all this
other stuff so it's a business model as
well
so that's both extremes hey more have
more kids every time i have a kid i get
paid 400 bucks but that's a horrible
business model but because the kid costs
you know a couple hundred grand but that
means you don't if you get 400
a kid you don't spend 400 on the kid you
only spend 200 on the kid and you send
them to public programs right you're a
horrible parent
but but that's also happening so a part
of this
believe it or not a part of this has to
do with the tax system
i know this kind of want to complete the
front angle a part of this has to do
with the tax system
a part of this has to do with churches
not doing their part they're looking at
when trying to get a bigger building a
bigger building a bigger building
a bigger bill we're doing another
building budget another building budget
another building budget right versus
let's actually go do the work and you
know and amen nothing against those
bigger buildings
absolutely correct but i i don't think
it's just one person or another person's
fault i think it is something that we
got to have more conversations about
and the extremes we kind of got to get
rid of the extremes in the room when
you're in the videos i agree
having said that we've got to get tom on
a flight off tom's got to go i gotta i
gotta give a shout out to somebody real
quick
real quick shout out to tom ellsworth
he's usually known for bringing his
big ass brain to the podcast that's what
you're known for but today you brought
your heart so all right
that's nice of you buddy thank you good
to see you i and i
and by the way yeah last week this
tuesday i thought it was your best
session on the podcast what you talked
about with palestine and israel
thank you i got so many commentaries
saying adam is a i'm changing my views
on adam adam actually educated me i felt
he was being very
look at us uh compassionate so if we're
in the moment of giving each other love
this was a good moment all right
everybody put your hands down
right now i want to give one last thing
here couple shout outs to people one
reuben uh gave 10 bucks pat i'm a fourth
generation barber
and we are working on an app that will
disrupt the hair and beauty industry we
want to join you
we want you to join the board wow for
72.10
you can be honest nicolo uh diversified
is caitlyn jenner series or not
interview her also
how come no stop jew hashtag or popping
up pat when are you having a
conversation for
just hands i'll pay to go okay fair
enough we'll
think about that after reading your book
and watching you for
your my team believes you will be a
great addition obviously you will become
a billionaire okay great i'm glad i'll
be a billionaire caleb talking [ __ ] to
you
which was great and we had a bunch of
other guys that had stuff but he gave me
five dollars to do 50 bucks to do it
gang
have a great one next tuesday same time
in the morning thank you everybody bye
bye thank you all bye
you